suite et fin de notre feuilleton
maintenant tout au long de la semaine
nous avons vécu la préparation des
différents spectacles du parc astérix
qui rouvre demain au public
tout doit être prêt pour accueillir les
petits et les grands les chanteurs les
danseurs les cascadeurs peaufine donc
leur préparation et on vous offre
aujourd'hui un petit détour par le
delphinarium
je suis une grosse grimace pour la m
vincent s'apprête à plonger dans le
grand bain énervé s'en défont soir on
dit pas merci de limère il faut pas
répondre merci
il est le premier des six cascadeur
débutant à entrer en scène aujourd'hui
outre la semaine prochaine la semaine
prochaine normalement ouais on se repose
on se remet un peu des blessures et pied
à prendre attaque une belle soirée où
avait pas des trucs rabat n'ont autant
vie obélix lui n'a plus une minute à
perdre
après six mois d'hibernation le village
gaulois rouvre ses portes et accueille à
nouveau le public dans l'ombre de bonne
mine
car il elle ne chante pas encore en solo
elle participe à la course poursuite
la mise en scène est plutôt rustique
mais les enfants en raffolent
le vaisseau venus du nord fait son
entrée c'est la nouveauté de l'année
première représentation est semble-t-il
encore quelques détails à régler
c'est parti bon et on a un problème de
sombrer face au treuil défaut pour
vincent ces partis main basse sur la
joconde est un spectacle réglé comme du
papier à musique
tout se déroule un train d'enfer
dans une mise en scène où 6000 et les
petits nouveaux sont intégrés au compte
gouttes
c'est l'une des attractions les plus
prisées même si elle n'a pas grand chose
à voir avec l'univers d'astérix
ici impossible de recruter du personnel
pour une seule saison
les dauphins et les otaries ont besoin
de stabilité affective au quotidien de
nos vins jusqu'au 18 heures on est en
courbe et mouillé
même si fais moi dit j'adore il fallait
dans l'eau pour garder cette vente
contact avec les freins aux côtés du
barde les quatre voltigeurs il y a deux
mois à peine il ne s'était jamais
suspendu à l'élastique
alors votre copain la joconde a été
impeccable pas une erreur les élastiques
impeccable aussi pas une erreur il reste
plus que vous je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte mais
la pression est sur vous la nôtre rennes
souffre d'une cruelle solitude or lui tu
vois il était un peu comme toi mais en
pire
quand je les ai eus à quelques années en
formation
lui vous voyez un escalier ou un truc où
il y avait un truc à tomber ils
pouvaient pas s'empêcher de jeter un
plaisir à tomber incroyable pour deux
jeunes mousquetaires le temps est devenu
du baptême du feu avec les deux pages
jamais très loin véronique la directrice
artistique apprécié la performance
allez
papa a pas peur
pour jean-pierre ce spectacle c'est
l'aboutissement de deux mois de
formation véritable stage commando pour
ses élèves
c'est la première lecture en éducative
car la première expérience de vie
je suis ému
j'ai pris
même s'ils sont congédiés par rochefort
je mangerai je me vengerai les jeunes
cascadeurs ont réussi leur entrée au
engagez-vous par toutatis au feuilleton
signé stephen despinoy francis forgé
alain du bardo vers elle et nicolas
bertolo si vous n'avez pas